the throng of cities the matrix of
modern life is propped up by people
whose work is insecure
but in the shadows there's exploitation
and it's gotten worse
shortly after dawn ivan commutes to
glassy west london originally from
ecuador he's a cleaner and paid below
the london living wage
since the pandemic when some staff were
let go he claims his workload has
doubled for no extra pay he was harassed
if he took a break and wasn't even
allowed to leave the building while on
shift
stories like his are often obscured but
not unusual in fact nearly half of
precarious workers surveyed by their
unions said they'd had pay withheld at
some point in the year to july
a quarter were forced to accept worse
terms one in five were too scared to
take time off sick and there are also
more reports of sexual harassment
early lockdowns and job losses left
workers with few alternatives and
therefore fewer choices
recent labor shortages might imply that
there are more options for workers more
bargaining power but for the most
vulnerable that simply isn't the case
the pandemics offered some employers the
excuse to embed exploitative practices
and for those who simply can't afford to
take even a week unpaid or who don't
speak english the risks are simply too
high this is compounded say experts by
inadequate safety nets very low
statutory sick pay and delays in benefit
payouts when the system allows core
behavior poor behavior happens there are
good secure jobs at the top and then you
have this other class of workers
essentially who don't have those
protections who are low paid they don't
have protection against unfair dismissal
they don't get redundancy pay
they don't have proper sick pay
as the winter and spiraling cost of
living sets in the fear of fighting back
will entrench
times may be tight for employers but the
unseen and the vulnerable should not
bear the brunt helen smith sky news